Biological databases have been invaluable
for managing these data and for making them
accessible.
Depending on the data that they contain, the
databases fulfil different functions.
However, one of the major problem is that
each of these database resources contains
a different subset of biological knowledge.
Although each database can answer questions
in its domain, it cannot help with questions
that span domain boundaries.
For example, the FlyBase database does not
know about orthology relationships, The Institute
for Genomic Research (TIGR) database can help
with orthology but not with map position and
the UCSC database knows nothing about the
fly.
As this example shows, researchers must become
adept at 'database surfing' to answer many
reasonable questions.
Imagine, life would be much simpler if there
was a single biological database.
But this would be a poor solution.
The diverse databases reflect the expertise
and interests of the groups that maintain
them.
A single database would reflect a series of
compromises that would ultimately impoverish
the information resources that are available
to the scientific community.
A better solution would be to maintain the
scientific and political independence of the
databases, but allow the information that
they contain to be easily integrated to enable
cross-database queries.
There are many integration challenges.
One of the most difficult is the one that
might seem the most minor.
How do you assign and maintain the correct
names of biological objects across databases?
For example, consider the DNA-damage checkpoint-pathway
gene that is named Rad24 in Saccharomyces
cerevisiae or budding yeast.
Saccharomyces pombe or fission yeast also
has a gene named rad24 that is involved in
the checkpoint pathway.
But, it is not the orthologue of the S. cerevisiae
Rad24.
Instead, the correct S. pombe orthologue is
rad17, which is not to be confused with the
similarly named Rad17 gene in S. cerevisiae.
Meanwhile, the human checkpoint-pathway genes
are sometimes named after the S. cerevisiae
orthologues, sometimes after the S. pombe
orthologues, and sometimes have independently
derived names.
A more subtle problem is the clash of concepts
as users move from one database to another.
For example, the use of the term pseudogene,
genomic variant and even the concept of the
gene itself can mean radically different things
to different research communities.
Some researchers treat the gene as the transcriptional
unit itself, whereas others extend this definition
to include up- and downstream regulatory elements,
and still others use the classical definitions
of cistron and genetic complementation.
There are also technical challenges.
The various biological databases use different
DBMS and none provide a standard way of accessing
the data.
Even more challenging is the issue of updates.
Biological databases are always changing,
so integration must be an ongoing task.
There are main ways in integration of biological
databases can be achieved.
First, link integration.
Link integration has been by far the most
successful, because it lends itself to the
haphazard nature of the web.
In the familiar and ubiquitous version of
this technique, researchers begin their query
with one data source, and then follow hypertext
links to related information in other data
sources.
Second, a variation on link integration is
embodied in the popular sequence retrieval
system, which is a keyword indexing and search
system for biological databases.
Sequence retrieval system is more sophisticated
than general web-based search tools, for example,
Google, because it recognizes the existence
of structured fields in source databases and
allows maintainers to explicitly relate a
field in one database to a differently named
field in another.
Unfortunately, link integration is problematic
on several fronts.
First, it is extraordinarily vulnerable to
naming clashes and ambiguities.
For example, a naive researcher who tries
to navigate through the Rad24 gene confusion
using SRS or direct database-to-database linking
might wander into the wrong gene family.
Second, there are update issues.
An outgoing web link represents a leap of
faith that the page at the other end of the
link is still valid or if it exists at all.
For example, if the curators of the S. cerevisiae
database withdraw or rename Rad24, they have
no way of informing all the databases that
point to the Rad24 page that an update is
required.
Third, view integration.
View integration leaves the information in
its source databases, but builds an environment
around the databases that makes them all seem
to be part of one large system.
Despite the appeal of this approach, the system
has failed to catch on with the community.
Fourth, data warehousing.
Data warehousing can be broadly described
as bringing all the data under one roof in
a single database.
The first step in data warehousing is to develop
a unified data model that can accommodate
all the information that is contained in the
various source databases.
The next step is to develop a series of software
programs that will fetch the data from the
source databases, transform them to match
the unified data model, and then load them
into the warehouse.
The warehouse can then be used as a 'one-stop
shop' for answering any of the questions that
the source databases can handle, as well as
those that require integrated knowledge that
the individual sources do not have.
However, it is more difficult to create a
data warehouse than it might sound.
The single biggest issue is keeping the data
warehouse up to date.
New information is being continually added
to the source databases, which means that
the new data must be re-imported into the
warehouse in a timely fashion or the warehouse
will go out of date.
To make matters worse, database designs do
not stand still.
Their maintainers are continually tinkering
with the data model by adding new data types,
changing fields and nomenclature, and changing
the relationships among data types.
This constant churn means that dump, transform
and load software that have been written for
one version of a database will not necessarily
work with a later version.
Fifth, web services.
An important variant of link-level integration
is the concept of the web service.
In this view, the heterogeneous collection
of loosely-linked data resources on the web
is turned on its head, and becomes a world
of services that are linked by service names
and definitions.
In such a world, GenBank is no longer a database
from which users retrieve sequence entries,
instead it is a service that transforms sequence
accession numbers into GenBank FLAT FILES.
This concept might seem a minor point, but
it allows users to establish a common framework
that encompasses, for example, the BLAST search
engine, which transforms a search sequence
into a series of similarity hit records on
a selected query database.
Finally, establishment of globally unique
identifiers.
Recall the issues that the same biological
object might have multiple names, and the
same name might denote multiple objects.
One approach is to designate an authoritative
names commission to manage the definitive
list of such names.
Suh effort is currently being handle by the
HUGO Gene Nomenclature Committee, or HGNC
in short.